[موسيقى]
بعد 43 عاما على استضافه العراق لبطوله
كاس الخليج العربي المعروفه بخليجي تعود
البطوله اليه ولكن بظروف جديده البطوله
التي ستلعب مبارياتها في مدينه البصره
يعتبرها العراق فرصه ملائمه لاجل اعاده
النظر في حظر الفيفا ليلعب المنتخب
العراقي في بلاده للمباريات الرسميه لكن
الجدل لم يتوقف خلال الايام الماضيه حول
البطوله
خصوصا مع تضارب الانباء عن رفض بعض
الفنانين لاحياء حفل افتتاح البطوله في
وقت تختلف مواقف العراقين حول تنظيم
العراقي لمثل هذه الفعاليات الرياضيه في
بلادهم المزيد مع زينب المشاط
فيفا على الملاعب العراقيه في نهايه عام
2019 بسبب سوء الواقع الامني تعود البصره
لاحتضان بطوله الخليج بدورتها الخامسه
والعشرين ولم يخلو الحدث من الجدل فدعونا
نرى ما حصل
فنانون عراقيون رفضوا دعوه الاتحاد
العراقي لكره القدم ووزاره الشباب
والرياضه افتتاح حفل البطوله منهم الفنان
كاظم الساهر الذي لم يعلن عن اسباب رفضه
والفنان ماجد المهندس الذي اكد التزامه
بحفل اخر من الصعب تاجيله الامر الذي لقى
عتبا كبيرا من قبل جمهورهما كما سنرى
الدول العربيه
افتتاح الخليج كاظم الساهر طلعت من العراق
وبدات بالعراق والعراق هو وصلك مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي هنالك جدلون اخر ورفض
يقابله تشجيع جمهور الخليج يجد ان العراق
حصل على وجه الخصوص لا تزال بيئه ملغمه
بالمخاطر بينما يشجع رياضيون وشخصيات عامه
خليجيه واخرى عراقيه لاقامه الحدث وحضوره
في المدينه الفيحه
[موسيقى]
ستكون هذه المره الثانيه التي يستضيف فيها
العراق بطوله الخليج بعد ان اقيمت الاولى
في بغداد عام
1979 وتوج فيها العراق بطلا انذاك اما
اليوم فتتعهد الجهات المنظمه والجمهور
العراقي بان تكون هذه الدوره مميزه جدا
وتبقى عالقه في ذاكرتي كل من حضرها زينب
نشاط صباح العربيه بغداد
باستادين متكاملين استطاع العراق تحقيقه
احد اهم شروط استضافه بطوله كاس الخليج في
دورتها الخامسه والعشرين استاذ الاول
استاذ مدينه البصره وهو ملعب ضخم ضمن
مدينه البصره الرياضيه التي اقيمت بتصميم
المعماريه المبهر يتسع لاكثر من 60 الف
متفرج وبجانبه ملعب اخر يتسع لعشره الاف
فضلا عن اربعه ملاعب تدريبيه استاذ الثاني
وهو ملعب الميناء الدولي يتسع لاكثر من
30,000 متفرج ويستضيف عده مباريات في دوري
المجموعات من البطوله كذلك فان رئيس
الوزراء العراقي مصطفى الكاظمي تعاهد بان
تكون استضافه الحدث الخليجي مميزه مؤكدا
انها ستكون بطوله استثنائيه تختلف عن
سابقا العراق في السعاده الرياضيه من خلال
خليجي 25 حيث من المتوقع ان تكون مباريات
بوابه لرفع الحظر على الملاعب العراقيه
ليعود المنتخب العراقي للاعب المباريات
الدوليه على ارضه وبين جمهوره
صفحه بيت ام البصره
[موسيقى]
هلا هلا هلا فيكم
هلا فيكم
[موسيقى]
هلا بكم ايا
مع السلامه نوركم اول
فرح
الكم تحت ظلالي يا
الفيوم
[موسيقى]
المهمه عراقيه
حياكم الله وتحيه طيبه لكم في صباح
العربيه وبالتاكيد اجواء مثاليه خصوصا في
البصره وتحديدا في العراق اجمع الاعتبار
انه الفرحه لا تسع الجميع باحتضان العرس
الخليجي الكبير وبالتالي الجميع شاهد
تحضيرات البصره الفنيه
اللوجستيه حتى من قبل الجماهير التي ربما
هي رقم واحد ستكون في البطوله من خلال
تواصلهم مع السوشيال ميديا واعلان ضيافتهم
لكل الجماهير الخليجيه التي ستحضر الى
البصره وبالتالي يمكن شاهدنا الكثير من
الايجابيه التي تحيط هذه البطوله وهذه
النسخه تحديدا وبالتالي رفض البعض من
الفنانين هذا لا يشكل ولا يؤثر على
البطوله حقيقه وبالتالي من يريد ان يحضر
فيحضر اهلا وسهلا بها فبالتالي من رفض
فالديه مشكله مع العراق وبالتالي اليوم
العراق امن والدليل انه همم الجماهير
الخليجيه توافدت الى البصره قبل انطلاق
البطوله معين وبالتالي شاهدنا مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وحسابات بعض المشجعين
الخليجيين وهم يتنقلون في كورنيش البصره
وبانحاء البصره وبملاعب البصره وباجواء
البصره وعوائل البصره وكرم البصره
فبالتالي كل المؤشرات نعم احمد يعني لا
اريد ان اتحدث معك في السياسه لكن السياسه
مرتبطه في الامل يؤخذ في البصره بان فيها
جماعات خارج اطار الدوله ميليشيات متطرفه
بالتالي هذه المليشيات لديها عادات تجاه
الخليجيين ودول الخليج اذا ما حضروا لكاس
العالم وهم قال الان موجودون ما الضمانات
بان لا يتعرض احد لهم بان يكون الوضع
امنيا
لربما ما تم طرحه ويتم طرحه لحد هذه
اللحظه اعتقد غير صحيح وان وجد فبالتالي
البصره مؤمنه البصره مؤمنه بالكامل وخير
دليل هو يجب استشاره واخذ اراء من يتواجد
في البصره الان من جماهير خليجيه من
لاعبين من مسؤولين من رياضي من اعلاميين
كثير ترى اليوم موجودين في البصره يمكن ما
احد يعرفهم متواجدين من خلال اعلاميين
كويتيين يعني اعتقد يوم امس وصل المنتخب
او فريق او ناديه الكويتيه من اجل
الافتتاح ملعب الميناء اليوم فبالتالي هذه
المؤشرات السلبيه وين نرتبطت السياسه
بالرياضه وبالتالي اليوم همم دليل من
الواقع الملموس من هذه النسخه هو انت تسير
بشكل ايجاب وبنسيابيه وان تكون هذه
البطوله هي النسخه المميزه فبعيدا عن ما
يتم طرحها وان كانت هنالك بعض الامور
خلينا نقول التي تستهدف هذا البلد لسنوات
طويله لكن اليوم سنثبت للجميع ان العراق
البصره قادره وبالتالي نحتاج الى دعم
الاعلام الخليجي كما حصل في نسخه مونديال
قطر فبالتالي كثير من الظلم تعرضت له هذه
الدوله قبل انطلاق البطوله لكن عندما
انطلقت التمسوا الشيء الحقيقي الواقع
بالتالي
النسخه العربيه
كبار وحتى اعلاميين كبار متحمسين لهذا
الحدث الكبير في البصره لكن السؤال
الرياضيه الى اي مدى ستعزز هذه البطوله من
مكانه العراق الرياضيه عالميا وايضا همم
ستخفف من الحضر الفيفا على الملاعب
العراقيه
همم
ربما هذه النسخه التي ستقام ستعطي افضليه
ودافع كبير للعراق بان يستضيف النسخ
القادم وبطولات قادم وبطولات كبرى حتى على
مستوى مختلف الالعاب فبالتالي من يحاول
تشويه هذه الصوره يحاول الابقاء على
العراق مغلق رياضيا الاعتبار انه العراق
اذا عاد رياضيا سيعود الى الحضن الخليجي
بالتاكيد وبالتالي كل المحاولات ستذهب
وتنتهي السلبيه ونعود بايجابه قويه وننطلق
من بوابه البصره على اعتبار انه لم يكن
حظرا جزئيا لكن همم هناك مباريات السابقه
اقيمت في البصره واقيمت في بغداد واقيمت
في اربيل اقيمت في جميع المحافظات التي تم
رفع الحظر عنها وبالتالي هذه النسخه وهذه
الانطلاقه بوجود نجوم كبار على مستوى
الخليج والعرب ستحي وتعطن انطلاقه حقيقي
للعراق بالعوده الى الحضن الخليجي مره
اخرى على المستوى الرياضي
هذا معنويه ورمزيا اليوم تقنيا احمد الى
اي حد البنيه التحتيه الملاعب اليوم مهياه
مجهزه لاستقبال هكذا حدا رياضي
[موسيقى]
همم ملعب الميناء سيفتتح اليوم وتم استلام
من قبل اللجنه الخليجيه ومن قبل الاتحاد
كاس الخليج وهو الان في عهده كاس الخليج
الملاعب سواء المدينه الرياضيه او ملعب
الميناء وبالتالي كل الامور جاهزه من
ناحيه البناء التحتيه اعتقد يمكن شاهدته
الارشاد الكبيره ومواقع التواصل خصوصا
للعمانيين والكويتيين والسعوديين
وتحديدا بعض الدول الخليج وهم فرحين
بالمنشات الرياضيه العملاق اللي متواجده
في العراق وتحديدا في البصره ويتمنون ان
تكون نفس النسخ موجوده في بلدانهم فهذا
ينطينا افضليه انه نحن نمتلك البنا
التحتيه التي تستطيع ان تقيم عليها
البطولات وان كانت قليله لكن نحاول العوده
من هذه الجزئيه ملعب مدينه البصره سيكون
جاهز ومكمل همم ستكون هناك تقنيه الفار
متواجده في الملعب يتسع الى 65,000 متفرج
وستكون شاشات محيطه في المدينه الرياضيه
لم يستطع الدخول الى الملاعب وبالتالي
ستكون هذه البطوله الجماهيريه بحته على
اعتبار انه الجماهير العراقيه ستتوافد
بشكل كبير الى البصره وليس هناك متسع
لمقاعد اضافي وبالتالي سيكون محيط ملعب
المدينه الرياضيه ومحيط ملعب او ملعب
الميناء وايضا المناطق المشجعين ستكون
جاهزه لاحتضان هذا الحدث الكبير وعيش
الاجواء البطوليه الحقيقيه من كرم البصره
وضيافه اهل البصره وكرمه العراق واهل
العراق وكل من سيحضر سيكون على العين وعلى
راسي
البطوله بطوله خليجي 25 ولا للعراق الحبيب
شكرا احمد رحيم الرياضي شكرا لك